what up space fam goes in here from
anime up we're back at it again to
discuss the latest developments in the
dragon ball super story
and this time goku got a brand new
powerful form so make sure to stay tuned
for that
if you do enjoy seeing dragon ball super
reviews on this channel then smash that
like button to keep them coming and
share this video with any cultured
saiyans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future dragon ball
videos make this the day you subscribe
if you haven't already and if you are a
dragon ball fan
feel free to check out the dragon ball
version podcast which i host with my
friend ray who hasn't watched dragon
ball or anime in general
we discussed an arc every week and
started from the beginning of dragon
ball
and now we're at dragon ball z which i'm
super hyped about so yeah if you want to
relive the greatness of dragon ball
or discover it for the first time check
out the dragon ball version podcast link
in the top of the description or you can
just look it up on spotify apple podcast
or wherever else you listen to podcasts
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all
if you'll remember last chapter goku did
something pretty stupid
he gave moro a senzu bean and then gave
moro enough time to fuse with the earth
so that in theory goku would have to
destroy the earth if he wanted to
destroy
moral pretty terrible situation to be in
now we get the perspective of gohan
vegeta and the rest they comment that
the planet feels off
and that their bodies hurt all of a
sudden it turns out moro is absorbing
their energy too and vegeta tells them
to get off the ground
and vegeta hits the nail on the head
when he says dammit kakarot
you've managed to screw it up again but
moro is not just absorbing power
from them he's seemingly absorbing power
from all the earth's inhabitants
leaving them feeling really weak moro in
classic bad guy fashion looks like the
epitome of gluttony right now
as he laughs and says that all the
earth's energy is his
all his this is definitely one of the
strangest fights in dragon ball where
morrow manifests
fists from the earth and begins trying
to punch goku with them
at first ultra instinct goku seems like
he can block them alright
but the arms keep on coming a third arm
shoots from the ground surprising goku
arm after arm shoots out and moro tells
goku that he has nowhere left to run
long story short it doesn't look good
when
asked if there's any way they can keep
moro from exploding whis answers yes
one method and wonders if goku will be
able to manage it
then something pretty crazy happens
beerus says that he'll lend a hand and
this
isn't what i wanted a deus ex machina
where beerus or whis just saves our guys
is not satisfying at all
luckily this ends up being more of a
tease with the mangaka seemingly
having some fun with our expectations
before he makes this
unwanted help disappear despite the fact
that they just had the menus issue
beerus is down to help because losing
earth would be troublesome
according to him he doesn't want to miss
out on all that quality food
he even acknowledges that he'd be in big
trouble if the other gods of destruction
saw him do what he's about to do
however this is all a red herring it's
misleading and just when it seems like
beerus will fix goku's mistake they get
terrible news that beerus has received
the summons from the grand priest
apparently they found out about merus
and beerus
is upset because clearly he's in hot
water and we all know
cats don't like hot water then we get
classic tundra-esque behavior where
beerus even asks krillin if he really
thought
that beerus gave a crap about the planet
he obviously does
but not enough to put himself in
jeopardy right now which is
understandable that's not his job
anyways and although whis
doesn't stay impartial he also doesn't
just solve the problem for goku
he tells goku that he needs to shatter
moro's forehead crystal
and that will release merus's power and
defeat moro
whis is obviously not being impartial
here but at least he's leaving the heavy
lifting for our guys
as they talk it is funny seeing how we
stops a punch
with one single finger effortlessly from
moro it's not even a nuisance for him
which is a pretty nice flex on lisa's
part right here
before disappearing into the angel realm
he tells goku to have faith in his own
strength
and of course we get a classic beerus
moment where he says that goku better
save some food
even if the earth gets destroyed that is
the top priority here for beerus or at
least that's what he wants us to believe
beerus and whis peace out so thankfully
we can't count on god intervention and
now the question is how is goku going to
win
the crystal begins to become less and
less visible as moro swells up with more
power
luckily vegeta comes to rescue he starts
using his technique for
spirit fission and releasing some of
that absorbed energy from moro
the crystal becomes visible again and
moro's body starts deflating vegeta
tells
goku to hurry on and goku says that
everything is riding on this fist of his
he goes flying off to the crystal he
breaks through earth and hand
after hand as he approaches moro's face
but he's stopped
right before he reaches it vegeta is
running out of time
since he can't drain moro as fast as
he's taking vegeta's power
and goku comments that he doesn't have
enough god power
then hearing god power joko heads off on
an errand
things look really bad now though goku
reverts to his base
black-haired form because his power got
sucked away
what is interesting about this part is
that goku clearly can't just
overpower the opponent on his own he
relies not only on vegeta's help
but on that of others including yamcha
tien and xiao tsu
piccolo asked if vegeta can reverse his
spirit fission
so that they can gather up ki for goku
and vegeta says yes
he starts collecting everyone's key so
he can recharge goku they get energy
from people at the sanctuary 2 and even
goten and trunks
who by the way have not shined in dragon
ball super as much as in dragon ball z i
wonder if we'll ever get to see more of
these two shine in future arcs
but anyways vegeta sends the key to goku
but it's only enough for super saiyan
blue it seems he specifically needs god
power and then they apologize since his
divine power is still developing
and didn't help then we see jocko
looking for majin buu
clearly he's the deuce that there should
be god power in him
that can be useful to goku back at the
battlefield goku looks completely
helpless
and he says sorry guys this is all my
fault and
yeah goku you're totally right here it's
totally his fault for giving moro a
senzu bean instead of finishing him off
hopefully he learns from this experience
but he's had
similar learning moments and that didn't
stop him from making the mistake here
still i hope maybe in vain that in
future dragon ball super arcs goku won't
make this same mistake again
but honestly at this point i wouldn't be
surprised if he does
yamcha hopes to bring the world back
with the dragon balls
but krillin says that moro will blow up
the whole galaxy so there will be no
more dragon balls to use if that happens
things really do seem hopeless and
vegeta notices that moro will explode
soon no matter what they do everyone is
pretty much preparing for death here and
yamcha says that after everything he'll
die a bachelor
and it's pretty funny that that's where
his mind goes to but yeah after losing
bulma
it seems he still hasn't found a wife of
his own you gotta feel for yamcha
he was one of the first characters
introduced all the way back in dragon
ball
and he doesn't get enough love at the
last minute a huge amount of divine
power comes their way and it ends up
being from ub
it turns out that the great lord of
lords divine power aka the grand supreme
kai's divine power had
gone to evil majin buu and was then
inherited by his reincarnation ube
after being woken up it seems like the
grand supreme kai manifests himself
through
buu's body and heads over to ube's
village and explains to him how to send
all that divine ki to vegeta vegeta
sends this to goku and i like how he
tells him to use it for another round of
ultra instinct i like the way he phrased
that
it hits goku and the power is immense
not only does goku attain mastered ultra
instinct again
the key around him also takes the form
of a giant goku looking avatar
that lets him grab on to moro's hands
goku brings the avatar's head close to
moro's crystal forehead
completely overpowering moro and then
goku leaves the forehead of this
giant energy avatar and delivers a punch
strong enough to break the crystal the
crystal cracks
and we smiles from space sensing that
goku got the job done without them
at last it seems that moro has been
defeated and goku turns back
and gives a thumbs up to krillin this is
a bit concerning because
if you watch dragon ball you know that
when he did that against piccolo jr
that look backwards and give a thumbs up
in dragon ball
he got an energy beam through the chest
but hopefully this time it
is over and i like the fact that a
buddhist and whis didn't have to save
the day
and b that vegeta came in handy as the
joko jaco was super useful actually so
props to him all in all if this is the
end of the moral arc i do like the way
they finished it off
again it wasn't really necessary to get
to this point in this way
when they had goku give more of the
senzu beans but nevertheless at least
vegeta got to help significantly
if it wasn't for him the galaxy would
have been destroyed so that's a win for
vegeta fans in my books
but anyways that is it for this chapter
let me know what you thought of this
chapter moro and this arc in general and
what you expect to see happening next if
you do enjoy seeing the dragon ball
super reviews on this channel then smash
that like button to keep them coming
and share this video with any cultured
saiyans that you know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future dragon ball
videos
make this the day you subscribe if you
haven't already and if you are a dragon
ball fan
feel free to check out the dragon ball
version podcast which i host with my
friend ray
who hasn't watched dragon ball or anime
in general
we discussed an arc every week and
started from the beginning of the dragon
ball story and we're at dragon ball z
now which is over 9 000 in hype level
so yeah if you want to relive the
greatness of dragon ball or discover it
for the first time
check out the dragon ball version
podcast link in the top of the
description
or you can just look it up on spotify
apple podcast or wherever else you
listen to your podcast
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord twigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one-tier patrons
the ones who stand on top all clans
ingrata the world acquire respect liam
thompson
pate heffa emperor otaku thomas jones
spidey life tinel
big buddhist rythean tungsten tarkus and
denki kaminari
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh who's the current
most donated overall champion
of the world steelers angel cruz anatoly
kazakie cricket xp joe stanton with aura
very gucci jessica kayla font alicia
actor hinokami and water bonnie parks
the red-haired raven florian joanne
garcia mcshamus jack watches anime
amanda c
deadly saint high school dxd73 matthew
cruz and
anthony schreiber thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already smashed
and a bunch of you have been doing that
so thank you so much to everyone who's
joined the channel as well
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer so whichever way
you choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you